[Music]
We have um VIP coding at scale. It's a
talk I'm going to give at the expo in a
very short version without all the
hands-on stuff. So this is whatever how
long this will take. It's all about VIP
coding. So we're going to give fully
into the vibes, embrace exponential and
forget that code exists.
It is about focusing on the output and
not actually on the code. And that's
where where people disagree like if I
don't look at my code as an engineer,
what am I? Um and then if what does even
embracing exponentials mean in this
case? So, and that's we're going to get
into that and but we're definitely going
to forget that code exists. And I think
uh the at the anthropic conference two
weeks ago was a great chart of how
exponentially agents run longer and
longer and generate more and more code.
So, slowly forgetting that code exists
and you want to review every piece of
code, but building trust and adding
guardrails to the AI is what this talk
is about.
And his VIP coding journey starts kind
of initially what people most people saw
of just like I built an app in just one
day and I put it online and I made money
and I then things happened to the app
and things got leaked and things were no
longer fun and that that's that fun
chaos state of vibe coding and we're
trying to move to professionals then and
that initial state is what I'm now
terming yolo vibes. It's the unofficial
wording, but it's all about creativity
and speed and it's a good place to be.
It's because there is instant
gratification. It's getting things up.
It's about learning. It's not about
shipping products, but and so we need to
get there.
Second stage is structured wipes. It's
all about balance and sustainability
like how do you bring mainten
maintainability more readable code like
things you might actually somebody in
the end might want to read that code and
you have a handover to somebody else and
you want to have some quality control
that what you built is maintainable and
not just a throwaway project
and lastly we get to spectrum vibes and
if you have done anything on Reddit or
on blocks in the in the past then few
past few weeks you've probably seen
people sharing their kind of best
practices. This is how I finally got
good value out of AI and those are those
best practices are emerging but they
bring you that scale, reliability and
velocity that that comes with that while
still hopefully giving you some speed
and gratification along the way but
reducing that chaos while maybe keeping
the fun.
So VIP coding initially where we see
this outcome first as I said it's all
about no you not don't even want to look
at the code like if you're in an editor
and I see actually people framing their
experience in AI editors of low code
mode so they they just look at the chat
panel and look at whatever comes out of
it and that's the outcome first. It's
all about natural language. It's all
about just staying in the flow and doing
working with the AI and it's about auto
accepting changes. So until it maybe no
longer works, we might want to undo but
otherwise we just keep talking to I know
you did this wrong. Try again. Um fix it
or go to jail is a very popular one. So
you can try all kind of but stay in
natural language. Don't don't be too
specific. So there is a use case for
that though. You wanna get a sense for
yolo vibe coding for rapid prototyping
for proof of concepts where you just
want to get something out. That's why I
actually have a ton of conversations
with larger companies who want to who
start a conversation like how can we do
white coding and for them it's all about
getting people who are non-technical to
be able to communicate ideas. It's about
UX people just making a mockup and being
able to bring that to a meeting and
being able to communicate what they want
to do in the mockup. It's all about
learning. Like I we had last uh two
weeks ago at build we had one hour vibe
coding on stage live and people build
games and I use 3JS which I have tried
many years ago but I haven't used 3JS in
a while but once I got the code running
I could start getting into how it is
structured how does it make shapes and I
could actually understand technology
because I have something working and
that's that's really the power of
getting something up and running that
that gives the technology something to
hands on to actually try out and of
course personal projects. So um I'm sure
how many of you had s sit down with
somebody who's non-technical and showed
them vip coding and just build a your
water tracking app or you build
something with your kids. There's all
kind of personal projects you can now
finally solve over the weekend thanks to
yolo vibe coding.
So let's do some yolo vibe coding. This
is AI generated. So the images do
reflect the vibe. So, this is really
about voice input, relaxing. I guess
coffee is in there as well, but let's
get it going.
Um,
okay.
So, in VS Code for YOLO VIP code, we're
going to start with an empty VS code.
So, hit command shift N. Sorry.
>> Are we supposed to use
>> I might show off insider stuff, but all
of what I'm showing is also unstable. If
you have insiders, use insiders.
Insiders is the pre-release version of
VS code that ships on a daily basis like
Firefox Nightly, uh, Chrome, Canary, Dev
Ships Nightly.
So on your left side, you will have no
folder open. On your right side, you
will have co-pilot open. Everybody got
this?
Raise your hand. Cool. Awesome.
So um who has used agent mode? Just
checking so not have to explain
everything. Okay, cool. So agent mode uh
the probably the default you want to
have set and default was setting. Um
clots on four is great at front end
stuff. So for me personally my my
favorite big enough. Yeah.
And now what's interesting so just one
one quick tour of how we're going to do
VIP coding is there's actually this
interesting setting here. This is
zooming. Yeah. Is news workspace in VS
Code. And for this first round of VIPE
coding, I want you to go into this tools
picker down here and actually disable
scaffold new workspace
because it will help you scaffold your
workspace, but it will lower the vibes
if you're just trying to do HTML
coolness.
>> Oh, yes. Uh tools picker down here.
That's the little one. Uh, how to get
into this menu? There's a tool this
tools picker.
>> Okay.
Uh,
>> oh,
yes, it might be in. It was in a
different spot before. Um, if you don't
see, check that you're in agent mode.
Otherwise, you don't have tools.
>> Yes. Ask mode. Yeah. Okay. First step
into the panel is switch to agent mode
down here. It should might be in ask by
default.
>> Yes, it is. Cool. And then second step,
go into the tools menu, which only
appears in agent mode. Soon agent mode
is going to be default. And this whole
where is my my tools picker is less of a
problem.
Okay. So, and then what you want to
uncheck is this new section.
>> And we're going to check out new.
>> Yes. Do you see nothing?
>> I see those two items and nothing else.
That's not enough. I I see more more
see. Um you might be Yes, I think that's
fine. Let me just
>> shoot.
>> Okay, good insider.
Yes, I think this is actually it's very
recent and we're actively working on
that. So, keep it keep it checked. It's
fine. So, let let's actually use it. Um
let's start with our first VIP coding
using because it's so hard to disable.
And the way we're going to do this is um
create a uh let's do react vite. And
that's first lesson for VIP coding. Use
stacks that are kind of popular in front
end where the AI doesn't have to reason
too much and make wild guesses. So react
invite are good ways to run a project.
Um website
that for what do we do? Um hydration
tracking
water hydration
water consumption app
simple
and big accessible UI
following uh what do we tell the AI to
make it really beautiful? We tell it I
like to tell it Apple
design principles.
You can infuse it with whatever design
sense you have. Mine is just make it
look pretty which always helps somehow
adding that extra. So right water
tracking hydration and that's so we
don't give it any constraints. We don't
tell it how many buttons like is it
mobile friendly? Is it not mobile
friendly? Is it um what CSS language to
use? Uh I might actually not do
reactivite but might Oh yeah, let's do
that with material design with material
material design.
So yeah, now we got a stack. We got a
design direction and we tell told it to
make it pretty. Okay.
And then hit run. So we're now in in a
no folder state. So what's first
happening? It's going to tell us to
empty to open an empty folder. Everybody
got that in there? Flow. Okay.
It's going to hit continue. Now it's
going to actually ask me to open a
folder. Going to make a new folder.
Vibing at
NAI engineering.
Put that anywhere
where you put your stuff, where you put
your code. And now it's actually opening
a new folder and it's going to continue
the setup. And to explain a bit what's
happening here. So this is using the new
command. A new command is is optimized
for creating projects from scratch which
if you look at the internet of how
people evaluate AI coding tools is what
every second person does. Can it make me
a water tracking app? Can it make me a
movie database app? And so we optimize
for this flow, but also it makes for
this nice vibe coding from scratch
because everybody struggles with what is
the right stack? How do I get started?
And this is what this is here for.
Uh we got the latest. So we we can now
review the commands. And this is maybe
where we do the first tweak of our
settings. So if you go into settings and
search for approve, you will find the
auto approve.
That's the first rule of VIP coding. As
we said, we we don't want to look at
code and we just want to have the AI do
stuff. So what you can do in my my case
I'm going to actually go to over to
workspace from user to workspace and
that means that setting is only set for
this workspace which is the safest way
to use this setting. So use with caution
are going to auto approve which means
all of these continue buttons won't
happen anymore and we're just going to
get results. So check that box close it
again and we can hit continue here.
This is using invite. This is fine. Now
we're gonna stop worrying about the
code. Uh but I can still read the plan.
So install materiali dependencies create
hydration tracking apple inspired design
and project structure.
So it's running commands. Um
why is there files already in here?
Okay, cool.
skips.
Where did it create? Oh,
the music come from
because I already did something. Cool.
Okay, we're on. Yes, keep going.
This case, I tried to create something
and then it ran another terminal
command. Keep going. That's fine.
Is it doing stuff for you? Do you see
things popping up?
Oh, proof.
>> Oh, wait. Did we That was in the last
version.
>> Okay. Okay.
Okay.
>> Let me let me check in VS Code stable.
[Music]
>> Yeah, that's my my problem of not being
enough in stable. I shouldn't run
workshops.
There you go.
>> Why is that different than
>> So you found it in
>> Thank you so much. There's two ways to
get to the same thing, but it's
different menu.
>> Oh, there
>> the settings.
>> There's settings from the bottom and
settings from the top. They're not the
same.
>> Okay.
>> I'm happy to go later. There's settings
up here.
>> I use the gear. I use the gear.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Where's the other one?
>> Oh, and the other setting. Yeah. Yeah. I
have customized my UI too much as well.
Cool. Question.
Yes, that's that's what we I think I
should have said auto approved before.
So, it's active for the chat session,
but this is the setting I just showed is
the is the auto approve. So, you all the
continue buttons are basically gone and
it just autoroves.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And for MCP tools, we
actually do have drop downs to allow
always allow for session and always
allow for workspace and or not always
allow. So there's some more fine grain
things we're rolling out to more tools,
but for Yep.
>> Yeah, I think it's the auto proof is not
applied to the current session. That's I
showed it too late. I should have done
it the other way around.
Okay, we got some material design coming
in. And this is where you need to get
your coffee and just wait.
>> That's a good idea. Let's do that. Okay.
Uh, open new window.
Um, okay. What What prompt did we use?
Create a right. So, okay. Now, in the
new window, I'm going to do autoproof
first.
Um,
approve.
Auto proof is already on. That's good.
Um, this is another window now. And
we're going to do the same thing. And
we're actually going to use material
design. I guess is still out there,
right? And or fluid. Fluent. That's the
Microsoft one.
Let's see what this looks like. Again,
it's going to prompt me for a folder.
Um, vibing
at
aie
two.
And this is I think one of the key
takeaways like trying out different ways
to get to the same result is where VIP
coding really shines is continue
is just trying I had really success of
just like what are different signup
flows that we can create like create
three different versions of this design
to explore what this could look like.
Okay, it installed.
It's up in the next in the in the one
script. And that's where it gets
confusing. If you have multiple open now
at the same time, you got to figure out
what's running what. And now this flow
actually over here runs without any
confirmation. So we we set auto approve
in a correct order.
And it's now just creating v installing
installing fluent.
You notice that we got the wrong fluent
because there's a dependency. Now it's
fixing those.
>> Yes.
>> So do I. Um I I do command comma is the
quick way. So I don't use menus. I
should use menus. Um so you go up here.
I have my settings up here. Most
probably have them on the other lower
side. and you go in here and go into
settings. And this is what it should
look like.
Do your settings look like this. And
then if you look for approve
sorry can't type auto approve.
Do you see it?
It might be insiders.
It's all blur.
We're shipping on a monthly basis and I
thought we tweeted about it end of last
month. So,
so you found it.
Okay.
>> I'm not trying to
use this. I want to stop
The challenge is auto.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm looking for that right now.
>> Yeah. The good thing the person who owns
the AI terminal integration just came
back from paternity leave. So we're back
on the game to work on it. But the um
there is definitely we've been looking
at how to allow specific terminal
commands and that's how most tools do
it. But if you think about the scary
parts of chaining and running multiple
commands in one command. So terminals
are not as predictive as you would think
and how you can easily allow list
things. So I've been mostly thinking
about the how to do it right. Right.
Okay. And I got two VIP coding sessions
going on here. and hide this one. This
is not this is for tomorrow.
This vibing is happening.
So what you see it creates an app tsx.
It creates an app CSS. It also creates
copilot instructions. Uh who's been
using copot instructions before? Yeah.
So that's that's one way. This out of
the box experience just does things for
you. It uh comes with instructions baked
in which is nice. It understands which
stack you're using. That's mostly about
it. It already captured my design
principles that I eloquently put in
please make it look like Apple and now
it's actually there's a clean, minimal,
intuitive interface, consistent UI and
everything else.
Uh it broke down the technical stack
even things I haven't mentioned like CSS
and responsive design. So it calls out
some of the assumptions that AI will
fill in if you give it a high level
task.
Okay, this is still working on the index
CSS and
the other one is working on the HTML
file.
>> Yeah,
>> it would just do it for it would usually
do it as it creates the project. I
haven't typed anything else so far in.
We're just we're just vibing.
it. Um, here created one.
>> Let me see if it created one both.
>> Okay, there we go.
>> Our first app is done.
Hydration tracker. Stay healthy. Stay
hydrated. Today's progress. We're on a
quick ad. 500 milliliters. And it went
with metrics. Isn't that beautiful?
Just how I wanted it. Maybe you got my
accent. I don't know. Um, we can do plus
minus.
>> It's interesting how mine looks
different.
>> Yeah, I know. I know. So, does does
everybody looks as nice as mine? Do you
already see yours? Okay.
>> Yeah, yours better.
Yeah, that's this like a very wide open
wipe coding workshop. Um, I ran these a
few times and this is probably one of
the nicer ones. So, um, but it's also I
like actually running these with
different models and getting a sense of
how good each model is at design and
having design sense without me telling
it how to do everything. And Claude is
definitely usually rocking the the
icons. It got the colors really nicely.
So, uh, that's been great. This is a
really nice app. So, now next on because
we're visual like we haven't even
checked the code. We haven't read the
CSS. We haven't looked at the TSX. like
is this still doing which is doing
functional programming like how does it
handle state I I don't I don't care it
works so now you can actually do a new
feature we landed you can now say
work visually so I can now say this
header up here I don't know what it's
called like whatever progress indicator
um let's make this
uh more animated
adding
particles maybe
that's good. So mu pet paper. So this is
all is this material design. This is
material design. Yeah.
>> I didn't I hit start down here. If you
have the browser preview open did it
open fail?
>> Cool. So this is um to point out two
features. So one is in this flow at some
point it basically started the task.
It did npm rundef
and then the next step it did it opens
simple browser and simple browser is
this VS code in browser preview we have
and it will just um what we're injecting
here what just went away is a little
toggle you can now use to select
specific elements that we then attach as
a visual reference reference and as CSS
into the current chat. So if I scroll
back down here, I see what's being
attached. Actually click it. So
everything you see under message is in
the context. The element screenshot
somehow didn't didn't make it through.
Uh but this one made it in. And that's
basically the the CSS description and
HTML of the element we attached. So I
didn't have to describe the element
where it sits. It just did it for me.
Okay.
Ran into snacks. We don't care about
that. Let's check the other one.
Number two, fluent design. Uh, this is
what it came up with. It's a little bit
plain.
Um, this is sad.
Okay, at least it has a goal reach.
That's nice. Um, and it has recent
entries, too. It made similar
assumptions on what we want. So feature-
wise it somehow got to the same
conclusion but design-wise
uh this is definitely more corporate.
Um yeah so that's the simplicity of VIP
coding and
using the new tool out of the box. Uh if
you are an insiders and you can disable
new tool it's easier to do like a single
file HTML thing because new tool is
definitely biased towards using npm and
installing packages. So it always ends
up a little bit more um complex.
>> Do you work with
>> Yes. basically the team I work on. So I
Hi, I'm Harold. I work on VS Code.
>> Yeah.
>> Really cool to understand
what are the new things that just like
like a quick dip somehow. Someone could
show me like I have them both on my
machine,
>> right? and I use them both but then I
like fall behind a couple days back.
What are the new things and why I should
be using insight? What's
>> Yes. So the the best way to stay on top
of what's new is so we we do actually
right now this week it's testing week
and we're writing our release notes. So
the release notes are usually capturing
everything that's new. But for insiders
it's hard because it's coming out every
day. So it's hard to point.
>> That's a great idea. We're going to make
an MCP server that summarizes what
landed. Yeah. Yes. I like that. Okay.
Okay.
>> Let's let's do it for the next next
demo.
>> Next demo. Okay. So, what do we have in
our YOLO vibing toolbox? We have the
agent. Um, which sometimes is hard to
find. Now, you're all on the agent. So,
that's great. It's all about um actually
didn't show that. I could have shown
that is different panel styles. So, if I
go back here um you can actually move
this into the editor.
which is nice. So, some people like that
more space for your chat. Um, you can
also,
if I go back into my panel,
>> oh, I moved in into a drop down here and
you can move your chats into here. So,
you can have multiple chats and they
actually have names. So, it's easy to go
back and forth. You can put them in
parallel to your codes. You can use all
the like window management things.
>> Yes. Wait, how did you know? Um,
okay. Where do we go? In new window.
>> There you go. Now you have a chat in its
own window. You can put it on your own
monitor. So, feature request succ. And
you can actually pin it on to be top.
So, now if I run this and I can close
this
uh
let's move that away first. So, I can
accept this. This we all going to keep
and close it.
and then close the other one. And now we
have the output and we can just move our
chat across and fully focus on the
exponentials
that are happening in this window. Yeah.
So that's one way you can really manage
the space how you want it. Uh new
workspace flow we showed. So it's really
this optimized
CLI first question.
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah. And then voice
dictation I haven't shown. Uh who has
tried voice dictation in GitHub copilot
already? Okay, magic moment of
um
add a dark mode please and maybe
give it a cool name that works with a
younger audience who needs to drink more
or maybe my kids. Make it for kids so a
little more kids friendly. Thank you.
Bye.
Okay. So, u command I is actually the
default shortcut. Um it's it's a local
model which is great for privacy and
it's really fast. Uh it's accurate and
there's an option as well if you when
you use command uh voice input that it
also reads back the text which is great
for accessibility.
And yeah, by using just your voice, you
can now finally don't put that coffee
down and just keep keep vibing. Uh
there's a hey co-pilot as well I think
we did at some point which I haven't
used in a while.
Okay. Uh
I said all that keyboard shortcuts.
There's a keyboard shortcut if you want
to customize it to actually hold down
while you talk and then let go. Uh
visual context I showed attaching. It's
great for wireframes. the in preview
gets hot reload. It just works and you
can attach the elements using that
little send button.
And then auto accept. I showed the auto
approve tool. There's also an auto tool
auto approve tool setting. Uh there's
also an auto accept after delay. If you
don't have that on, I love autosave.
It's a great VS code feature that's
already working. Um basically after
delay or after focus change, it will
just save it for you. And what I haven't
showed, let's see if this this works.
Here is the undo button.
This is still going. What is this doing?
I forgot. Um Oh, this is adding the
particles. Cool. It still worked on it.
Got to compile it.
Okay. Got stunning animations. That's
great. That's what I wanted.
Is it doing it now? So, let's keep
it does animate. Nice particle. Nice.
Look at bubbles. Okay. Um I don't like
it. Undo up here. Uh those are basically
our our checkpoints. Uh there's a new
checkpoint UX coming. But because I have
many people saying tell me, "Oh, you
don't have checkpoints. I can't undo
stuff." But if you already accepted
stuff or if you want to go back to
something like this is like these
particles but for for V0ero. Oh, that's
beautiful. I love it. Uh we don't need
that. Then you can also bring that back.
I just need to see that again. That was
really nice.
Okay. So
for people who don't like particles, we
can now undo and it's now back to the
original version. So it it has stages
for each of the of the work it did. You
can easily go back and forth to see the
before and after as well.
Yeah, but in VIP code, you don't want to
look at the code because we don't look
at the output.
Okay. Um, that's the YOLO toolbox.
And I think as I mentioned before, you
want to try it out just to get an idea
of the AI. Like in my case, I mentioned
I like getting a sense of how good AI is
at design. like can I just give it wide
task to explore a space and it will like
come up with something interesting or do
you need to how detailed do I need to be
when does it make mistakes if I give it
a general task maybe about Java where
it's not as good at like what will it do
um next one is known frameworks we went
with V material design things that are
kind of off the shelf and haven't
changed in a long time uh in a large
scale so you want to use something
that's popular and have has been
consistent
And lastly, we use it as a whiteboard.
Um, we showed there just attaching a
visual element, change this, add some
particles. Um, it's really about not
being becoming too attached with
whatever you're working on, but being
um, able and willing to throw it out and
start from scratch if things go wrong.
Structured VIP coding is this middle
stage. tries to balance the yolo, the
fun and chaos with a more structured
approach. And there it's um I think it's
the biggest impact I see from talking to
customers on like this is this is how
VIP coding can work for us. This is
where we can bring somebody
non-technical in. give them a good
starter template that has a consistent
text stack that comes with clear
instructions for the LM and how to work
on it and keeps it in its actual
guardrails
and already brings in some custom tools
that bring in expert domain knowledge or
internal knowledge that you would need
to work on this codebase
and that's really kind of yolo on on
guardrails. uh it's faster and gives you
more consistent results. So you don't
end up with something, oh it used
material design but it should have used
fluent or it used should have added dark
mode and should have been responsive.
All of that can already be baked into
the instructions.
So I see a lot of companies bring that
into their bootstrapping for green field
projects. So we have something and you
can often times it's you go into a
meeting and you have a product that
looks already finished because you
vipcoded it with your go-to stack. It
uses your internal design system. So it
already looks way more polished.
And the last piece I think out of
mainstream workloads is where YOLO by
default will always bias towards
whatever is like top of the training
stack. With this one, you can then
customize it further down to internal
stacks, internal workloads, internal
deployment infrastructure that makes it
work better.
So let's do structured VIP coding. This
is now the image as I explained is now
has wireframes and uh more charts. So
that's what makes it more structured.
There we go. It's open.
So what I'm going to do now I think I'm
going to push this.
It's still running.
Let's see if this runs. I did
create this vibe coding. I do have
another one that I can share. Just look
at this one. And I'm going to push it to
GitHub.
It's gone through fine. Um, cool. Front
end vibes. Perfect. Um,
this is all vibes. So, we're going to
make this live. Um, this is commit
and then
Yeah. Oh, yeah. commit misses one who
has been using this commit button here.
So cop will write your commit message
then this looks good and now sync
changes and I'll share the repository
this repository might still be an old
name. Let me see.
Yeah, probably. Let me just check where
it sits because I forgot where it sits.
Oh, it's perfect. Sleep wipes.
This is one of my VIP exercises. Okay.
>> For browser window
>> which the
>> just open.
>> Oh yes. Yes. Um yes the simple browser
simp. So we go into
simple browser show. That's it.
Sleep wipes.
Okay. And then npm install on it. And
then yeah,
it would have prepared better. It would
have been a code space and a dev
container and you just click open in
code spaces and things work. Um, come to
my next show and then we'll get that
fixed.
Yeah,
let me just open the code space to see.
Now I'm curious if it just works.
Anybody's been using code spaces on
GitHub?
Not many. Okay. Occasionally
>> the complexity lies in all the different
versions of
regular version all the work. out of
bugette. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Everything just work.
>> Yes, it mostly does, right? But mostly,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> It's 95% there.
>> But it's the 5%. When something doesn't
work, you just go back.
>> Yeah.
>> You could try. I haven't I'm actually
not running it in container but if you
wanna
>> the container is just a NodeJS one and
it should work too. I did add a
container. See
>> I vip coded my container too.
Wait I can now check. So if you ever
wonder what you did on a project um
so this is where I created my container.
This is where I just asked uh GitHub
copilot to update my dev container. just
look at my codebase and update my dev
container. So I did a good job here.
Should have maybe
remembered that I did that as well.
Okay, if if ready meanwhile why you
clone while you npm install anybody got
it working already
still. Okay, cool. I'll give the tour of
what we have. So one is we again start
with good copilot instructions and they
live in github/copilad-instructions.mmd.
It's a markdown file that's included
with all your agent requests, all your
chat requests, all your inline chat
requests. It just copilot basically
gives a grounding foundation knowledge
about your codebase. And sometimes they
feel a bit repetitive like um depending
I saw some demos of like use basically
it repeats linting rules that you expect
the AI to just follow anyways. But I I
like um my go-to is just a oneliner on
what what's your stack. That's that's a
good starting point. Just point it to
what frameworks, what version. And
that's one way to just keep it on rails
with what what it uses.
>> Question.
>> I was experimenting with this figuring
out what would be the best way to have
that be a standard that gets included in
but like let people not not mess with
that like give people some coding
structure.
>> Yeah,
>> if you have a whole team of
probably don't want to touch it.
>> So this is in your repo. So I think it's
a good team exercise to iterate on it
like it shouldn't be a stale document.
You can put this in your user settings
as well.
>> You probably don't want it with each
app. You probably want to right
>> you could do it set up a way that you
code and then each app.
>> So I've been trying to convince on my
peers on a GitHub site this should be an
organizational setting that people can
set easier on like a organizational
level and like something as a as a team
you can select which ones you want to
use. So working on that discovery
sharing is there always one file or can
you opt in for like you have different
languages different things you're
building.
>> Good question.
>> Yeah. So we have this one now. This
these are new instructions. So they
these are these become rather monolith
and large and unwieldy.
And now uh just point out here before I
go to new ones I do also guide which
tools to use. I do have my first MCPS in
here and I already tell it for front-end
Q&A and review use the browser tools
that come from playright research. I use
perplexity. I have uh context 7 in here
which has library docs and it keeps
using this ID tool to look up IDs but I
just gave it these are the IDs you
should use. Don't don't use the other
tool. So there's ways you can already
guide it to specific tools you want it
to apply when needed.
Um the rest is just syntax formatting
optimizations um
key conventions. Yeah. And then the
other format we have is github
instructions.instructions.mmd.
And those have this front matter syntax
that's becoming more popular for rules
of what what files it should apply to.
So they start to be scoped with a glob
pattern and then right now they're
limited to being applied. You actually
have to have the file in context. So a
TypeScript file would only be applied if
I actually do have a TypeScript file in
here or I do have one open and then I
enable this context then then it would
be applied. But if I only have this
right now, which means this isn't
included, it wouldn't actually apply the
rule. We're we're fixing that and it's
going to be more
working as expected probably. Um but
that's that's right now that's like the
biggest question I get like it didn't
include my rule because right now it
really wants to see that file.
Um yeah so those those are new uh those
shipped I think the last version so they
should be also in stable and we're
actively working on those. So, and then
the the new new thing is plans or
prompts. And there we have the first
kind of reusable tasks for as a team.
How do you think about
ingraining like, oh, we now have finally
a way to tell GitHub copilot to write
tests and your AI champion in the team
handcraft this this perfect prompt which
oneshots your test
consistently and now everybody shares it
in Slack, copies it around. Once you run
the right test, you go back to Slack,
copy it back, and that's what you want
to use prompts for. You can finally put
these prompts into a place where they
can just be used by everybody. And how
can they be used? So I showed these can
actually be be attached. So you can also
go in here
and attach instructions. So you can you
can do it manually too. So that's one
way. But I can also now go in here. I'm
in the chat window and hit slash. And I
can now actually run user prompts that
are my own that I create for myself. And
I can you use my plan and spec prompt
you see over here on the left.
>> Can you make that custom? Yes, these are
custom ones. So the ones I have here,
these are already custom in the
workspace.
And then the other ones
I don't have I'm not showing. So I think
we do there's a new menu.
>> Yes. Yeah. Yeah.
So let's make it here. Um,
so this this one actually just landed
yesterday because insiders we can now
finally have an entry point because
everybody kept asking how do I create
prompts and I have to tell them which
command to find it in. So this is the
new prompt configuration file and I have
some already here. So as you mentioned
like this is one that's interesting for
um if I open this one this is like
defining how I want to write custom
instructions. So whenever I'm in a new
project that doesn't have custom
instructions yet, I do run this prompt
to to bootstrap them for me.
And yes, there should be a prompt
sharing website where you can find these
amazing prompts that I create. And next
week we're going to
>> So each problem is like a separate
separate from each other.
>> Yes. So that's the main difference
between instructions. instructions are
you can have multiple if you work on for
example if you have one for TypeScript
and one for your front-end folder they
do combine because there's multiple
instructions that hopefully don't
conflict with each other um but they
they allow you to be attaching multiple
instructions and they're really more
about code whereas prompts are basically
uh easy ways to inject something in this
prompt field and they stay in the
conversation but They um they're mostly
around a task and maybe giving the AI
something like specific to do.
Instructions, you wouldn't necessarily
give it like what to do, but more how to
do it.
>> What about if you wanted
to
always do TDD?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So TDD um good point. Uh
that would be a good way to use custom
modes. So if we go into here,
custom uh mo sorry. So this is only
insiders because it just landed. Sorry,
you can't follow along or if you're not
insiders. So custom modes will show up
um in the dropdown. So this is like
going to now it just went into the menu,
created a custom mode, and now I can
pick where it shows up. So got github/
chatmodes which put it into the
repository or I just want to keep it for
myself. So a good pattern if you just
want to experiment put it in your user
folder. If you want to make everybody's
life better in your team and you have
high confidence that your mode does that
then you put it into the project.
And then uh we're going to do name this
one TDD.
And then we're gonna
ask AI to fill it in, right? Uh prompt
um expert expert prompt uh for just
typing.
Hi there AI. We need a prompt that
enforces testdriven development uh for
GitHub copilot. So it should probably
first make sure it understands the
problem then write tests first and only
after tests are done maybe get
confirmation from the user to then write
the implementation and then keep running
the tests against implementation. Cool.
Thanks.
It's important.
I didn't know I didn't say I'm now
worried because I didn't actually
activate my files context. Let's see if
it
I think it should have a tool to just
create modes for you if you ask it. So
it's gonna going to make that an MCP
server next.
Okay. Oh, it got it. Okay. Oh,
wonderful. So we have a test driven
development assistance. This is my code.
We want read the code. Test development
assistant core principles understand.
Red write failing tests first.
Beautiful. I wouldn't have not green.
Wow, it does follow refactor, improve
code quality, strict rules, noation
tests. Beautiful. Beautiful. So, this
our new TDD mode.
Um,
>> we've done it four. Looks pretty good.
It has emojis
example. Should we try it out?
Okay, we have
>> um
>> use a framework. It's framework
independence. Looks like
>> Oh, just Yeah, I think it does some
Yeah.
>> Okay. So, it has it right there.
>> It does make some stuff up. Yeah.
Wouldn't need to do that. I can take
this out. I already have my so
um cool test drive the design wonderful
okay let's do it so we have this project
which doesn't do anything if you just
run this um
npm rundev probably doesn't I think I
already did this before so this is just
a basic plain landing page so let's do
the um what feature do we have I want a
dashboard for GitHub issues just use
mock data because I don't want to wire
it up to GitHub. So, we want to have
maybe some interesting contribution
metrics. And but first, actually, let's
make a plan.
Meanwhile, while I type this in, let's
stop it. Um, TDD.
So, dashboard for GitHub.
Um, don't worry.
So now again we give it a very broad
task but we can now put it into TDD mode
which is our new amazing test and
development mode that follows all the
best practices I assume that the knows
about TDD
and let's see
>> so wait that's you created a new mode
there
>> yeah because so we went previously went
into configure chat modes we created a
new mode this mode is Now enforcing the
technique we can actually in a mode you
can say which tools it's supposed to
use.
>> So
>> is the mode
in agent mode but based on file. So it's
a it's a custom agent mode.
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> When is that going to be live?
>> Uh it's in insiders now. It's going to
ship next week on on the 11th.
>> Yeah.
Insider ships.
>> Insiders ships daily, but it only
releases monthly. Yeah. And we're one
one week late uh because there was a
short short week, so we adjusted our
schedule.
Yes. Um so for most of you this menu
will just have these entries and the in
insiders only
if you look for modes in the command
pallet. So command pallet you can also
click up here show run commands and then
modes and that's that's the place
Yeah.
>> Yeah. Are they in in the output or in
the problems view?
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> It if it runs the commands itself, it
will start looking at the term. So the
easiest way if you if you run the
deployment and the scripts itself
through co-pilot itself. But otherwise
there's also context actually if you
look here we have um the
is actually
terminal last there's terminal last
command which includes the output as
well in term selection. Now if you ask
me why they're not in the at context I I
couldn't tell you right now. Yeah,
but yeah, that's working. I think I did
this thing wrong, though. TDD,
let's just see.
Oh, the tools. It configured it made up
tools. So, it did that's that's the part
it made up. This actually those are not
the right tools.
Um, this is why it didn't do anything
was when I it just basically acted like
chat and gave me the code because all
the tools it tried were
uh it didn't have any right access. So
let's try this again.
So this probably a good good point to
good thing to point out. So in now
prompts as well. Let me open plan
prompt. So this one can actually now
said tools
and if you just make a tools entry here
to tools
you can now actually click here and say
which tools in this case this is a
planning prompts. So mostly you probably
wanted to look at perplexity
to come up with anything it needs to
find on the internet. Uh I can select
that. So that's the way you can now have
tools constrained for a studio prompt.
which which always helps with kind of
higher quality because if you have many
tools which as you install more MCP
servers you always have this tooling
explosion and they might solve all
different problems you're having
throughout the day but now you can
configure it more specifically for
domain and
also insiders only we have tool
groups uh tool sets as should we call
them so tool sets I And how do I get
here? Um down here in the tool dropdown,
configure tool sets and add more tools.
This I think sends you to add server,
but configure tool sets. Open this
opens this one here. And that's only for
>> servers, right?
>> Anything both built in and MCP actually
a lot of the tools you see here, we
cleaned this list up. If you use
insiders, you see them. Then these are
actually tool sets already. So we use
tool sets internally because edit files
has multiple ways to edit files. We give
the AI a few ways. Uh codebase search
has grap has file search has different
searches as well depending on what
you're looking for. So all of these
actually are tool sets in our own back
end and we expose this now as something
you can create yourself. So my research
tool for example has the perplexity tool
to ask deep research questions and it
also has fetch
No, I didn't. No, we can show.
>> Yes, I can. Wouldn't be a talk without
MCP. This is
also there's a talk tomorrow about MCP,
a whole talk track where I'll be talking
about MCP if I can finish my slides.
Um, okay, there we go. So let's talk
about MCP. This is doing
something. Let's see. Not
understand requirement. It create mock
data. Redph face writing tests. It wrote
tests. It Oh, it found that there's a no
package library. That's that's sad. Um
and it created the test utility
and then it tried to run the tests.
Um and then it asked to proceed. So
that's cool. So it did the first stage
of that mode. Um but I don't need to go
too deep. But but that's modes TDD. It
will ask now for because we asked it to
ask for confirmation. So that's why it's
now pausing. It wrote tests. Uh they're
all red. So that's good.
Okay, we accept it. And let's go into
MCP. So MCP servers, who has already MCP
servers set up in their VS Code?
Good. Okay. Um,
one way to get SP servers is editing
JSON. And that's really, um, there's a
few other ways, but let me show you
another way. Um, Playright MCP. Who's
been using Playright MCP? It's probably
one of the coolest ones. Um, so
Playright MCP is a browser testing
framework and allows people to access
the browser locally and just take
screenshots, run websites, get
accessibility audits, a whole bunch of
utility in there. and how to get it for
VS Code. There's a JSON blob that you
can all ignore and just hit install
server.
So install server is just a VS code
protocol that we use to just wire things
up into VS Code. You see the same if you
go to the extensions marketplace for VS
Code, you can hit install extension that
powers the same process. So now I can
inst um don't hit show configuration. We
need to move this down. But install
server actually puts this now into my
user settings. And so you can see you
can have MCP servers both for yourself.
And I have the one for GitHub and for
GPAD which is a cool one. I can
recommend this one.
And then yeah play right now. So you can
already see how many um tools I
provided. You can see if anything fails
you can get to the output.
If there would be configuration, I can
show that here. There's actually just
pad needs a GitHub token. So, it's a
local MCP. And what have you ever seen
that one? So, yay, no tokens in my
configuration. So, you can use inputs in
VS Code configuration both in the
MCP.json and your settings. And inputs,
you might have already seen those in
tasks.json is how you configure your
tests and your build steps in VS Code.
It's the same system. Um, they're
defined up here. So, inputs are just an
ID, a type description, a default value,
and the password true means it's
encrypted at rest after you put it in.
So, it doesn't ask me more.
>> That's going to prompt you.
>> It would if it but this this shows
basically that it already has a token.
But if you enter it the first time and
we can actually try that if I
>> where is it actually
>> uh in VS codes key storage. So if on Mac
it actually uses keychain.
>> Oh okay.
>> Yeah. So
>> what other MCP servers?
>> Yeah. So I can show um JPAD is fun. It's
done by actually um Zia GitHub. So
Jispad.de justpadmc that's mostly I'm
going to show it off tomorrow as well in
my talk. Um, but it's a fun one that
uses uh gists as a knowledge base and
also for prompts. So, I really like this
one. Uh, it adopts a ton of like recent
MC MCP stuff, but I think the main ones
we usually see is GitHub MCP server
just pet just
>> lost in tangent.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. So this if you just want to play
around with it with a really well done
MCP server, then that's that's one. Um
not saying GitHub one isn't as good, but
it's um
there's a lot more coming here as well.
So they're all in like really active
development to figure out what the best
way for MCP is. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> Right. And in your case, that server is
already running. So, how to hook up?
>> Okay. Cool. Yeah, let's do that. So, SSE
um same way basically. So, what just
finding my
max it out? So, go back to my MCP. JSON
and down here.
>> Yes. So, to clarification, MTP.json sits
in docs code right now and it's per
workspace and that's shared across
everybody. So hopefully it puts stuff
either you work on it alone and it's
just for you or everybody is happy to
have those MCP servers.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. And then the what's
now if you hit add server you will find
what you're looking for.
And then from ads server you can hit
down on HTTP. So we actually do support
both SSE which is actually deprecated
and streamable HTTP which is uh the the
new fangled easier to scale better for
your cloud.
>> It's no long in the spec. Yes. And we do
fall back to it on a client side but
it's it's the SSE is really hard on on
hosting right because they have these
long running connections long
>> long. Yeah. Yeah. So
yeah, so that's that's where you put in
your yeah your MCP sec server. And if
you want to do it manually, it's really
just um
you get a nice autocomplete too. So if
you pick a name
example and um this would be the type
would be
not studio actually it's http yeah you
already would you would use http and I
would already yell at you that you don't
have a URL so I'm going to put URL
so this this is how uh everything is by
default as stdio once you have a URL
Well, I think I can take this out. Yeah.
So, would be just that entry.
Yes. So to get Yes. Um so many demos I
see people hit start here as well just
to see that it's working. It's a nice
configuration that just make sure it's
working. We actually do cache the tools
once we saw them the first time. So how
MCP works is that on the first init
initialization from the client to the
server, it shares its tools back and
that's what you see here, the one tool.
So if you would do it right, you would
never know the tools unless you start
the server. We actually cache them. So
you don't have to we don't have to start
all the servers proactively once you
open Copilot just to get the tools.
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> No, actually you want to be in agent
mode. Agent mode ask mode will not run
MCPS for you. uh you can you can go
uh because as mode is not uh it's not
actually there's no function calling
inherently right fun as mode is really
this traditional askd question will
answer based on its training there or
its context
um
yes so there is also an ask what you
don't have tools you would see it um but
I can do actually does this still work
Um,
let's do that more quickly.
I think we actually do this still.
Yes. So, we're actually blurring the
line a bit now. So, if you do That's not
working. Okay.
Yeah. But if you actually reference
specific tools in ask mode, it will
invoke them for you. But by default, the
the way where you want to execute tools
is in agent mode.
Yeah.
>> Uh they're all coming through GitHub
copilot. So they're all using your paid.
Uh you can add your own models. Anybody
has tried it managing your model? So um
so I have gamma 3 through lama which
runs locally and I have open routers
perplexity R1 uh which is actually a
fine-tuned model from of deepseek R1
from perplexity. So if you haven't tried
it yet, uh basically go into the model
picker and hit manage models and then we
we can actually custom configure your
own API keys from Enthropic, Azure,
Cerebras, Grammite, Rock, all of these.
Um Olama is the local one. So if you
have a beefy M4 Pro, I'm still sad how
many models I can actually run on this,
but but eventually it's going to be
small powerful models. Um that makes
sense. So
Uh, it might be because of your
anthropic tier, right? That's
um or is it
>> you have four? Oh. Oh. Uh, the other
one. Yeah, you might be in agent mode.
So, we do actually filter them down. So,
that's an ongoing improvement we're
doing. That's why it's not it's right
now a preview feature only because we're
still having to connectly correctly wire
up which model allows tool calling. So
there's some some every provider has
different indicators of how tool calling
works and that's that's one of the
matching things we're doing right now.
So you might not see it because it's not
on our our list yet.
>> Yes. Yeah. You you will see that. So if
I do just um one example here
uh so just bad so a you can disable them
if you already if you want to be faster
you can do command down and just go
through. So contact 7 is the one I want
to keep player I can disable right now
but once you start using them
>> this is command up and down the power
user way of navigating
those. So these are all built-in MCP
servers. And once you start, you can
actually now if I want to be very
explicit and I know which tools I want,
I can use my tool sets or I can mention
specific tools that are um in in my
list. But I can also now just go in and
say what do we want to do here? Um
research
uh
GitHub metrics.
Let's actually use the research one
because we created it.
Sounds better when I use research here.
Use it in a sentence
for productivity.
And what happens now is uh this one has
now is an agent mode. We have the
research group set or tool set. So we'll
either use perplexity or fetch.
And one of my perplexity keys actually
outdated because it failed before. Let's
see. Okay, so you see I already actually
proved this before. So you see a that it
runs the server and you actually click
the server to see where it comes from.
Um if I would have not autoproofed this
because auto proof is still on from our
previous session, you can actually go in
here and edit what it's sending.
Um which now doesn't make sense because
it's it's already sent and then it
writes up uh what it found in this case.
Does that ask?
>> Uh, that's just the odd name for the
perplexity tool.
>> It happens to coincide.
>> Yes. Yeah. Yeah. It's just um the verb
should be before. So, it's their their
naming. Yeah.
Yeah. So, that's now run two. It
actually did a follow-up query as well
and explained it. And now I could put
this in into a spec as well. It's
actually I did this before. So I wrote a
spec using for community dashboard. So I
did the research using perplexity and
then ask it to write a spec from it
using a little query I have here for the
spec. Um
so that's one way you can quickly get
things done.
And just to point out this one, it's a
pointing it to the spec. So these are
actually resolved by the AI. So if you
point it to specific files, we do
actually validate those as well. So if
you get them wrong, I think they're
underlined. Um, you can also click them
so you get all the markdown
goodies. Um, and then you just ask it to
write on the spec. Do nothing else. Uh,
use perplexity to look up stuff.
Don't lose details. Keep updating the
spec. So that's that's one way to work
on specs. There's probably more more
tools we we're going to add here. Yeah.
So that's MCP. Any other MCP questions?
uh per MCP. So the MCP itself doesn't
run anything except when you support
sampling
which we do on insiders. Sneak preview
for tomorrow. So but yeah, if you use
sampling, actually I guess I have to
explain sampling. So as sampling is a
way for MCP to reach back out from the
server to the client to use the LLM on
the client and it's you can often think
the best use cases are to summarize use
cases are if you want to um reduce the
amount of tokens you send to the back to
the client to explain something. So
there's a few ways, but um overall
there's not enough integration of
sampling. Um but so we are the first
ones to to get it out there because we
already have the LMX posts. So that's
cool.
>> Yeah. to pick the model kind of.
>> No.
>> Yeah.
>> But it's still hardly
>> right. So,
>> so
>> yeah. So, what I recommend is a in in
your modes boil down the tools to what
you actually need. So reducing the tools
manually either deterministicity already
in in your prom. So this prompt could
have tools for like what it should
actually do right that would be one way
and then I can configure what do I
actually want to have here like this
should be only doing perplexity because
I it needs to do research and that's all
it should do
>> with custom mode that
>> custom mode. Yeah pockets of like this
like this right then you kind of pick
your pockets of
>> Yes. So custom mode is one way and then
the other one is you can actually
mention specific tools. So if you go in
here into add context and then you can
actually point it to specific tools. So
you're not doing like the look up things
on GitHub and you try to find the right
verbiage that it gets the right tool.
You can just actually mention the tool
of it should um for example resolve lab
ID. So so you can just add these here
and then it will be handed to the AI of
like these are the tools the user wants
to use.
It's it's still
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> Yes. Yes. Tool calling is inherently
always even in this case we're telling
the AI it should use it but it might not
use it. Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, my timer is down to zero.
Maybe just go back to the slides to wrap
it up.
>> There more, right? Um, wipe coding. So,
we showed workspace instructions. We
showed dynamic instructions which only
applied to parts of the tool set. Uh we
showed custom tools playrite deep
research. Uh I haven't showed using web
docs like actually one of my favorites
just point it to an existing repo and
say read this repo if you have
questions. MCP works great for that.
When I work on MCP server I just tell it
look in the TypeScript SDK server from
the context protocol if you have
questions. Because we have cross repo
search it just works. Um the agent
actually has access to problems and
tasks. So if you have tasks set up and
you have linting set up, things will
just work. So make sure those are set up
in your template. Um generate commits I
showed. And then fine grain review, you
can pause at any time. If it asks you
questions, you can always type something
in and keep steering it into right
direction. And you can trust read only
in specific tools. And I showed you also
editing.
So
yeah, uh instructions keep refining them
as it makes mistakes. One of the key
ones is commit often. I didn't show
commits now, but anytime you have a
working state, just make sure you commit
it so AI can continue making mistakes
and be creative. And then last one,
there's a clear pause button in the
lower end. So if AI goes off and you're
like, what is it doing? Like is it just
doing the right thing? Just just pause
and review. And that's possible as well.
Uh I showed a bunch of this for spectrum
development already but it's really
about having a spec having having a like
done a plan and doing more custom
prompts and tools which I showed
um showed us prompts. Um there's more
MCPS for database access and logging and
project tracking like the GitHub MCP
and there's also access to actually
tests and do debugging within the agent
as well. So if you ask it to test driven
development like we did, it will
actually start running the tests if
they're set up in VS code correctly. And
then we talked briefly about models as
well. So if you want to use 03 for any
of the cool stuff, the the deeper
thinking, you can do that as well.
Um
specri is really about focusing on the
spec and I think a great way to do that
is just create the spec from all the
conversations you had about the spec.
So, one way if you have a transcript
from a meeting about the project you
want to do, just feed that in and make
sure you call out what the final
decision is. It's a great way to have
meetings, but it's also a great way to
not write the spec yourself in the end.
Are there any tools to determine whether
spec
>> right
>> I would ask
and say what are things missing and how
could it be better and stuff like that
and we basically argued with about
Yes, arguing with AI is one great way.
So if I I have focus on one run prompt
um or prompt
is where's one critique idea is one I
like of just ask me three questions
about my idea right just have AI go into
thinking mode like what would you ask
somebody for feedback
um and
have it critically analyze your stuff.
So these prompts like those are
basically the next level of prom
crafting where you don't just ask it to
code but pull it in as a thought partner
as a design partner as somebody who can
poke um holes in your I
so
yeah um front view steps is yeah
>> a plan you you now can create one. So we
have don't have a plan mode built in but
we also know askedit agent will not be
there forever. So it's it's a like
series of evolutions. RU has way more
modes that you can customize. So I think
we want to allow developers to create
their own. Um because I even see very
few demos of people in client using
plan. They just give it a thing and then
it runs right.
>> Yeah.
>> It is. Yeah. I mean planning in in VIP
coding you even do planning and then
writing the implementation plan. So you
would spend way more time on that
initial just what and how we're doing
things and then you let it implement. So
that would be even plan
write the implementation plan or like
write the spec write the plan and then
implement. So you would even have three
modes if you do it correctly and then
yeah so that's probably the last one. So
takeaways, you got to experiment. You
got to figure out what works for you.
Like at what point can you just give it
a task and it runs with it? At what
point do you want to give it a task and
write a spec first and then implement um
keep giving it feedback and iterate. So
never just accept a bad answer and then
really work on your process like what
what works best for you, what works best
for your team and use modes and prompts
and instructions to ingrain that.
Um there's some bonus mistakes you can
screenshot.
>> Yes, please. One more. There's one more.
One more screenshot.
>> You can end up like major modes. You can
have multiple minor modes.
>> Minor modes. Yes. That's kind how you
end up with problems in custom modes
right now. So I got to clean this up
too. And then yeah, lastly
there is there is a sweet spot for how
you define your code bases for AI. So
you want to have well structured
self-explaining code. want to have the
instructions set up. Want to have
examples in your instructions. I want to
keep instructions updated. So that's it.
That was my unplanned workshop. Thank
you for coming.
[Music]